foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
whatever
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you should be able to hear us now man
this this thing is so hard to maneuver
around man
oh okay so I see
that uh
the updated is there
oh
yeah that's weird I thought our names
would be under it it takes away view
space
yeah uh this kind of format's hard to do
in general
I have to put I'll fix it a black thing
right there
um it's cool because what I'm about to
do is I'm about to let me just go ahead
and put up the
the first thing we're going to talk
about because I I messed around for like
two hours yesterday but this is this is
something different like what I'm have
to do is I might have to put a black
screen there in the middle uh that way
uh it separates us because the problem
is is it's not separating us
uh but I could fix that let me go ahead
and do that so what's what's going on
King let me put something up there so
you guys could see something there yeah
so uh yeah I said I would be wearing uh
the Whatchamacallit shade I mean uh
glasses
shades for iron Lords this is R and R we
know or no baby
yeah well I I don't I don't do shades
hell no you have blind anyway you
already know how blind I am
Chase is always your thing it's not
really my thing
all right so last Supremacy what's going
on people this is like I said my updated
version it does work a little bit better
uh but there is things I still want to
do I still want to put a spoiler alert
somewhere on here now I do have the
spoiler alert here
I'll put it up right now but I need that
black screen
so it actually like shows up correctly
ah Mario the movie
yeah because what I want is I want this
gift to be transparent and I want it to
be
somewhere on the actual overlay I don't
want it to uh to be something that uh
comes up randomly like that would you it
takes a little bit of time we have to
work on it it's not a big deal though
but we'll get it so what what do you
wanna what do you want to address first
king do you wanna I wanna address that
attack on Titan all right all right
let's start with the attack on Titan
because I'm sure there's people in the
chat that's been uh interesting you know
I didn't realize how many IOP members
that we had that actually like anime
until we started talking about it on a
couple podcasts
anime and video games go hand in hand
brother like uh music and Combat Sports
just so all right Attack on Titan what
what tell the audience what episode
you're on I'm up to episode four okay
all right so I um we got from the the
boring first episode and got to the
second episode where the Titans want to
come in and eat people Mamas and then
um the third episode where the dude want
to join the military
and it's it's kind of funny
because
you start to see the show start to take
some shape right because I'm interested
in a hungry girl the girl I always want
to eat food the girl that was in the
middle of basic training orientation
and she want to eat a potato
yeah the drill sergeant is talking to
her and she want to eat a potato
no
so I'm interested
so but but I am right though when I was
saying that the show does pick up like
you know
it's definitely
it's definitely one of those things
where it's it's weird on how it goes
through you know what I'm saying like
it's weird how they like start the show
but you know I I can't say that the
show's bad though like um you know right
now you're in like a lot of the World
building
uh because it's a show that's not like
the normal So you you're seeing a lot of
that building going on
um you know even though like popular
anime is like my academa
um you a lot of those demon Slayers sure
they're different concepts but they're
kind of rehashed from older animes you
know what I'm saying yeah Attack on
Titan is kind of like it's Unique like
there's not an anime like it
well it's so far
um
the character to try hard character I
want to know if somebody did sabotage
that belt or did they do that for his
ego to give him some confidence so I'm
gonna find out about the drill sergeant
because the drill sergeant comes from
his village
so it could be some favoritism there
so they're still in training where
you're at right oh we got a sticker from
drive by Joe that's from sub drive by
Joe three dollar sticker that's what's
up say something brother
all right so they're still in basic
training and you know you got dudes
that's forming little clicks right now
and I'm gonna get to the next episode
after that so yeah um nothing fantastic
happened yet you know what's funny
you're starting to get a little bit more
interested
and the show doesn't really pick up
until after basic training because
pretty much what happens after basic
training is like stuff just goes down
like immediately like there's no like
you know like a lot of these shows TV
shows movies they have like that little
like something like basic training will
happen and they'll have that like
letting all that knowledge they got sink
in and then they do something they're
like okay we got all the knowledge next
episode bam things go down like I mean
that's I'm looking for bam things go
down oh
the funny thing is when bam things go
down it never stops going down like it's
literally every episode something else
have you ever watched Baki I've heard of
it I've never watched it okay so all
right good you got me watching this I
need you to watch uh Baki all right
don't watch bakihama that's the next one
right but watch bakkie first all right
so Bucky is I think that's on Netflix
yeah that's on Netflix bro yeah okay I I
I'll try it out see what the buck you
got going on for it I I love that stuff
I love I love the tournaments type type
uh feel of it I I love the next
Challenger uh these dudes are so op so
strong so crazily ridiculous and this is
the stuff that I grew up on right so I
think you're gonna like this stuff
um because of Dragon Ball Z because of
Nora 2 and stuff like that but again
this is grounded so grounded in some
form of reality right because there's a
lot of unreal stuff that they're gonna
do but grounded in the fact that these
dudes are land-based and they're not
flying in the air and stuff like that
yeah okay I'll try it out um
let's see you're on episode four
get to episode seven and I'll do four
episodes of bulky all right no doubt
okay and and I got the next show all
right so listen guys
um we're gonna start putting up
um
polls
to see what movie you want us to watch
next all right and we're gonna start
being a little bit more interactive
throughout the week we can put a poll up
you guys are gonna vote and we're gonna
go uh you know pick the movies off of
there so
um right now what what what's the stream
we got we got Paramount we got Netflix
we have
um
Amazon
who will
Crunchyroll
so we're gonna pick like four of them
and you know from each one like off like
four of the top titles and and just see
what they do I actually watch smile
you did yeah I watched it with my girl a
couple nights ago because it's on
Paramount close
I gotta check that out yeah it's it was
okay it was okay it's one of those
little weird movies that you had me
watch the last one
no I I think smile I no I actually think
that movie was good I actually had a
couple people hit me up saying they're
gonna watch it because of our show oh
that's what's up yeah I had to do it in
the background and I got to tell you to
show that uh he told me about so um I
get a lot of DMS so please guys don't be
disheartened if I read your DM and I
don't respond but most of the time I
really respond right away
so what we're gonna do we're gonna hit
the Mario uh second trailer first
yeah so have you watched the trailer
because I I watched it you know what's
crazy this trailer had Mario Kart in it
it had multiple aspects of the show it
did show you a little bit more of Luigi
yeah first off you know what I want to
talk about when it comes to the Mario
thing let's let's Branch into
just general game switching to movies
because I feel like re like up until
recently it's been a Miss Miss hit like
very few hit but now you got all these
games coming you guys uh you know you
got uh The Last of Us halo from last
year well this year you got
this Mario game coming out Sonic and I
feel like Sonic was the exception
because most game movies are not that
good but now you're starting to see
people taking our lore seriously because
I've always said it I really like the
show Wednesday I've not watched it but I
like the success that the the uh that
the uh the actress that played Wednesday
has right now because she took that role
seriously because she respected the law
the lore in the character and she was
able to breed that to life in the way
that actually makes sense and that's why
I don't like I don't like when I see
like directors and stuff say dumb stuff
like don't don't play the game or don't
catch up on the game like it's just like
dude you you could easily make something
appealing that's gonna appeal to
everybody without crippling the
character that we grew up playing
yeah and I felt I feel your um your
anger when it comes to the Halo stuff I
thought Sonic was uh taken with a lot of
care when we initially first saw Sonic
and our bad reaction to it they took
note they went back they revised them
and anyways
and you know but it made the money that
that's the reason that when that
happened you could look up me on Twitter
I'm saying I don't care how many of
those movies they make I will support
every one of them because that is one of
those scenarios where they could have
easily went with that because it would
have saved the millions but because they
went back to the drawing boards like
look we might be able to get this to a
pilgrim the majority of people but the
people that love this brand The Gamers
they're not happy we got to fix it and
they fixed it and now since they went
and they they cared about the product
they did now look what's happened
they've gotten all of this success over
it fantastic but all right so back to
the trailer of the Mario the second
trailer because the first trailer was uh
uh introduction basically to the
overview of the world right this joints
yeah it was nuts like do you yield but
this this one
shows me
they take uh Smash Brothers Melee uh you
know Smash Brothers
into account they take in the Mario
World into account they're taking Mario
Galaxy
then Big Ticket Mario Kart
um I want to know if they have any form
of Diddy Kong Racing and I want to know
if the the the cars transform
it was so much of Mario and so much of
respecting all the stuff that Mario's
done even Luigi the fact that he's a
coward excuse me and they showed some
forms of Luigi Mansion
they're really respecting the character
and I think this is gonna probably be
uh to hold my bear moment from Nintendo
you know like this is how we want to get
it done this movie's gonna make a lot of
money
yeah I'm probably going to see it at
least at least two times I'm I I'm a one
and done and Man one and done and watch
it one time I think the only okay I I
remember what's funny is uh my friend
Tyler's in the chat I went and watched
one of the Twilights I think it was
eclipse
and I after like I'm not even joking
literally right after Eclipse they show
up and they're my ride home King and I'm
like well I'm like I'm ready to I'm
right I'm ready let's go chill man he's
like no we watching it I'm like oh so I
gotta watch it twice like back to
backing back to back my scenario is
let's say if it's not the weekend that I
got my son right then you know me and my
girl go sit me and you got it we you and
I have to see it right on the premiere
date so we go and see it if that's not
the weekend that falls on with my son
regardless to what when I get him I
gotta go see it again so I'm figuring
more than likely I'm gonna see it twice
if it so happens that I got them that
weekend the same day that you know we
got to go see it fine but yeah more than
likely I'm seeing it twice
I think
I think it's going to be good wow I
think I think uh you know what is your
opinions on
on Chris playing Mario
Chris Pratt I think I don't I don't have
uh uh it's a voice actor
you know do I want an Italian poem and
how racist do I need to be
like I don't I don't I don't care and I
thought he sounded great I thought the
my concern
and I I know he's a phenomenal actor
because I've seen his movie so good you
you've made me cry you've made me laugh
I love your stuff I'm not worried about
him as an actor and his acting chops
are you going to get the character
correct with the world with the CGI that
was my only and my biggest concern when
I saw Donkey Kong
and he looked just like Donkey Kong and
Mario looks like Mario and toad look
like Toad the only problem is
people are in an uproar over Princess
Peach
she looks like Kylie Jenner
and that's fine
no more problems
I think to me it's
as long as he plays the scenario like
look does he sound identical to Mario no
but I feel like he sounds enough to
where it's not an issue I I don't I
don't see his character and feel like
his character in the way he sounds is so
unlike the original character that it's
going to ruin the movie sure he sounds
different but to me it's no different
than people switching up who plays
Batman in the anime how many lines does
Mario have in his games
Mario that's it
so everybody's getting uh weirded out
from a startup screen from the uh from
the Nintendo 64. no come on man remember
the the startup screen he was like yeah
like gravity you play his nose yo we
found out by mistake cog found that
because uh we left him with the
controller while I left him with the
controller because you know I picked up
the Nintendo 64. and that was the first
place I went straight to the house and I
had left the control I think I went to
the bathroom he's like yo you know in
the title screen you could pull on
Mario's ears and his nose and do all
type of weird stuff
yeah I just
it's like I said when it comes to this
I just want them to do justice that's
all like I think so far it looks great I
think that you know in the next couple
years because they've been like TV and
movies have been in books for so long
and I feel like they're starting to run
out of books to make stuff about and
they're starting to slowly creep into
the gaming portion and it's just like do
it right man because I you know Resident
Evil the movie the TV show that's on
Netflix ah
like you're talking about the the the
animation no no I think those are okay
I'm talking about the animation was cool
the TV one uh I didn't see Resident Evil
TV show yeah look and what's funny is
like people trying to like bring race
and stuff into it because they changed
Western to Black and I was like that's
literally the only good thing about the
show like that like out of everything
that was wrong with that show that was
so far beyond the worst like hey at
least they picked a competent actor to
play Western that's all I I care about
because at the end of the day no don't
don't you're good listen
you're good I like to consume all types
of uh different uh genres of movies
right and I don't care if it's a b film
I'm gonna do it oh cause I got I got a
film for next week I'm gonna reveal it
at the end I got our film for next week
you're gonna love it because I loved it
I'm pretty sure that you're gonna like
it super b super cheesy stuff but oh
super b super cheesy Stuff you're gonna
have me watch something crazy yes yes
it's got Barbarian boobies in it
okay as long as you keeping me away from
that man it got something worse oh worse
oh God you know it's all right my aunt
is like the king of b-rated movies like
she does nothing but watch could be
right abuse I'll be walking and I'm like
what do you watch it should say the most
bizarre names
and I'm like okay
I got somebody that can give her a run
for her money
uh my stepdaughter Chantel
is the Bee Movie Queen
I said B movie yeah I saw that
she goes to the movies to see B movies
there's a movie she went to the movie to
go see Barbarian
that was in the movies yes and she was
there open tonight
it's sad that
the reason they picked these big actors
and these b-rated movies because when
they go to the movie theater they know
that people are going to gravitate
towards these big actors more than
they'll gravitate towards the plot of
the movie so that's how they try to get
some of them in there
yeah I mean he had it was some good
actors now all right so all right we got
Mario out that way we got our hopes and
our fears out of the way you want to
attack The Flash and get that out of the
way and then go straight to the the to
the Big Kahuna pull a truck yes yeah we
can talk about the Flash
yeah Ezra Miller is a psychopath
yeah allegedly I think my thing with him
is it's just like how do you how do you
do what you guys do and expect to get
away with it
all right let me read the super chair
real quick and I'll get right to that uh
Tyler from Crosby uh two dollar Super
Chat well 199 two dollar Super Chat my
man Tyler game too I don't care they
took they took a penny from you Tyler
love what you guys are doing the show is
great thank you so much it is ever
evolving share it out if you have any
criticisms if you have any suggestions
uh hit us up with it uh so we can you
know make sure that you know
actually with the high school with that
dude
oh you did yeah
oh man that's a great thing Tyler thank
you thank you I told him we was doing
something like this he's like I'm gonna
check it out thank you brother thank you
yeah I just the Flash
he's messing up the universe yeah well
see what Tyler told me because he he's
the dude that keeps off all this stuff I
don't know you know I watch it when it
comes out that's as far as I go pretty
much yeah brother it might not make it
well he told me the reason that they're
probably gonna push it
is because they have a what's what I'm
looking for they want they're trying to
get to where they were able to do the
flashpoint and with the fly uh because
after the flash point they'll be able to
um
to like restructure of the universe yeah
all right so let me give you the
breakdown Flashpoint in the comic books
was a jumping off point for The Flash
and it did a lot of huge things for DC
uh Universe right
and it was a good thing this movie was
supposed to be that this movie was
supposed to actually give us a Flash
movie that is competent and and decent
but I thought I I don't like Ezra Miller
as the flash never did I didn't like his
run I didn't like him as the flash right
character I like characters I love I
love I love Gunderson I love him better
you know I thought he had he was a
better president for the flash but it's
fine okay
that aside the flash point is their age
of Ultron is their movie that has so
much tied to it that it is going to span
different movies so so much is heavily
invested in this movie
they went back to do so many rewrites
and reshoots uh they took away Michael
Keaton's Batman because it was going to
go back in time for that Batman they had
that Batmobile in order to put uh this
guy's uh Batman and um
what's the guy with the big chin that I
I can't stand this thing you know the
guy that played Daredevil that messed up
my Daredevil movie
um
yeah so they got Ben Affleck there now
um playing that part I don't know how
it's going to take with fans but again
this movie is very
integral to their plans for the DC
Universe and I think
um
it is going to work
but they're trying to let the fans
forget
what Ezra has done
or has alleged to have done right and
it's so much uh with what he's done
that this stuff is borderline felonious
right if not felonious so the studio was
like or they wanted to cancel it all
together do you kill him off as the
flash do you replace them in one of the
timelines as one of the flash characters
somebody else knew to get rid of him
he has to go yeah because he's done some
crazy stuff and like it to me at this
point you
you either recast and we kill him and
pick another flash to be in this
building like yeah uh you know they I
actually I know it's probably not an
option but I would really like it they
got the dude from the TV shows playing
him I love that I think I thought he
respected what's funny is uh Tyler's the
one that got me into that uh to the
whole DC thing he's the one that like
showed me arrow and all that and like
they had such a good thing going on
there and it's just like I don't
understand because if you look at it on
Marvel Marvel's like we're going to take
Daredevil we're gonna let him come back
you know what I'm saying yeah it's just
like why doesn't DCC they already have
these characters like they already have
them cast like the perfect ones there
let's and I'm not saying there's other
people that can't play The Flash etc etc
but I'm saying if you already have one
that people Vibe with and like why are
you looking for another Flash
before it was a scheduling conflicts
that's the rule that they used they used
the scheduling conflicts uh because of
the TV shows and how the show was being
run now they didn't want to link the
continuity to a continuity that they
were destroying right because they were
they were killing off that Universe the
Warner Brothers TV line uh all that
stuff it was killing that Universe off
and they knew they was killing the
universe off they don't want to tie a
new universe a potential a money-making
character to a dead universe and and
there's a stigma that goes with Big
Screen Actors and TV actors
right and they don't believe that TV
actors can bring in big screen revenue
and I believe that's a falsehood I
believe he built a fan base I believe
that the fans will come out to see him
just like you said you endeared yourself
to the character through this guy so of
course you will go to the movie to
support him it's like that the TV show
was a success I don't know it's the same
thing I feel about blade and Wesley
Snipes like it's good like I'm gonna
give the new Wesley Snipes the new blade
a chance but because he's a good actor
and I think he could do that but it's
going to be hard for me to put up that
barrier you know what I'm saying it's
like because
in a way blade was the original
introduction of me into the into the MC
Universe like back way back then and
what's funny is that even at that time
King I didn't even know it was a comic
book movie like it was just oh it's a
Vampire Slayer it's like there's like
Dope music yeah I really didn't know it
was it was it was a comic book movie for
years and I'm talking years I didn't
know it I probably watched all of the
blades before I realized it was a comic
book it was a comic movie yeah
and and I think that's a lot of people's
introduction to the character
that you know
I thought that they did their character
a disservice but knowing the cast
knowing the directives
knowing the people that were involved
with the scripts and stuff like that I
can understand why it went the way it
was
Marvel wasn't ready I remember Marvel
was in a selling phase at that period of
time there were in uh bankruptcy and you
know God Rest uh Stanley so Stanley did
the best that he can do to get you know
his IPS out and he did a fantastic job
they all came back at the end so
hopefully uh Mr Ali can definitely bring
across uh that cottonmouth uh feel
to to Blade that he brought in um this
guy's show especially like I remember
one of the first things I saw blade is
when they're in that hospital at the
beginning of the first movie and he's
and he's trying to finish off her
because she got bit and that [ __ ] comes
through and starts shooting him and he's
like what you doing like
yo this guy said
best opening scene
Don sicario
you're not lying the Rave scene from
blade one yes
when the when the vampire when they let
the blood drip down
and then Blaze you see blade against the
wall and the frost and everybody's in
there
oh man
I'm gonna have to go watch it again yeah
that that's part of the reason it's like
it's just it's gonna be so uh there's
characters that I feel like could be
replaced they would you know there's
other people like even the flash I like
that dude but I feel like they could
find uh no I'm not talking about well I
know that but I'm talking about like
it's gonna be hard for me to mentally
separate them and then it's like you see
people like I feel like Robbie Downey Jr
I don't know if there's another actor
that could have played Iron Man quite
like that you know what I'm saying like
I feel like um I got a couple of people
I feel like maybe Doctor Strange could
be recast but he did such a good job
like there's people that I feel like
couldn't be requesting there's people
that I feel like did such a good job but
there's another person that could have
took that role if it was given to them I
feel you I think Dr Strange ain't
letting it go um let's be honest with
you uh Mr Cumberbatch has uh held firm
in in his stance as Dr Strange and I
want him to get that seminal movie I
thought the first movie had potential I
thought the second movie fell a little
bit short I think his third movie will
be his Coming of Age movie kind of like
uh Chris Hemsworth and Thor hey I think
they messed up when it come to his third
movie because they tried to implement so
many variables and elements into one
movie it's like we want it to be a
horror movie we wanted to do the second
movie though no that's what I'm in his
second movie like that thinking about
him in Spider-Man yeah he's like we want
to introduce the horror aspect we want
we want to have a a key component like
uh like Scarlet witch in it and we also
want to introduce the Illuminati
and and we also want to put uh well
America Chavez listen the the thing
about that movie
was the script was uh and it's kind of
like the Justice League
two different directors
two different thought processes with the
script
and if you can get the original director
whoever did Ragnarok that's who needs to
do it all
for Thor Ragnar yeah
that's psycho watiti though
was he not that and you didn't like him
in love and thunder well that can't be
the same dude you're not telling me the
same dude uh throw the whole dude away
then you know he he had one and done
yeah into it for you I guess he leaned
too heavy into uh the comedy aspect of
it you know okay I'm I've been thinking
we'd do this but we'll do this next week
I want you to go home
and list all of the phase four movies
from the least to best and we'll go over
it next week all right all right so
let's get to
remember what I think is probably
the best dude bro movie on Netflix
rocking right now
yeah I watched it bullet train yes sir I
actually think that this is a very well
done movie like hell yeah it's kind of
surprising that they are able to get
this movie the way it was
and I think the reason that
the movie does so well is because it's
it's different but not different at the
same time you know what I'm saying like
bullet train what I love is tangerine
and what was the other it was tangerine
and lemon I love those characters and
what's funny is the whole movie you know
okay let's not spoil what do you think
but um yeah no we're not gonna give you
any spoilers for this movie this movie
stands so strong in understanding and
learning the characters is fundamentally
grounded in in a space that is
unbelievable but yet believable that
this can happen in the circumstances
that it's happening I love Brad Pitt I
love ladybug his name is ladybug guys I
love Brad Pitt
The Reluctant Hitman
who took a job because somebody got sick
and he was at the wrong place at the
wrong time but he was the right person
for the right job
it is amazing you know what I love is
just his humor you know I've seen I've
seen Brad Pitt in humorous videos like
we were talking you know Mr and Mrs
Smith I think he did a very good job in
that but it's just like
this this was the least forced comedy
relief I've ever seen in my life like
he's like and almost everything Brad
Pitt said was funny like he literally
there was no serious moments for this
dude but none of it felt forced not one
bit of it it felt so organic I see I
love the guy from Atlanta
um
oh he was he was in King Kong versus
Godzilla uh the black guy uh lemon right
and tangerine is the guy from um
uh uh kick kick butt kick you know y'all
know what I'm talking about uh so he's
from um I could say it's a movie title
Kick-Ass he's from Kick-Ass and remember
he was in Godzilla the first one this
guy matured into such a man because we
watch him grow as a boy
into this assassin that's on the train
with his brother who we didn't think was
his brother but if you keep watching the
show and you go find out some stuff
I didn't know
certain people was in this film and I
said are you this budget had to be crazy
yeah they kept introducing people like
crazy like especially when you find out
who plays that dude
he popped up on the train of like yo
they didn't just do that they didn't
just do that you know Zaza beats I love
her and she's in the film yeah I'm like
yo this is Yo they had the girl from the
boys in them they had the the the the
the Asian guy from here the Asian girl
from the boys uh that has the
superpowers they had her in there they
had the guy from um Heroes the Asian guy
from Heroes I love that I watched that
show all the way you know they had So
Bad Bunny they had Bad Bunny and they're
playing this guy called wolf an assassin
called wolf
if you don't know who Bad Bunny is
addict and I'm pretty sure you probably
don't know him he's a reggaeton artist
or a Hispanic artist that is hugely
popular hugely popular yeah I love you
know we'll get to spoilers here in a bit
we'll probably I'll put the spoiler
thing up in like five minutes guys but
it was just I really enjoyed it and I
felt like the beginning was really slow
to me like it I was like
um you know but like once
the actual reason the movie's called
bullet train because they're on a bullet
train the whole movie and once that part
actually starts and they start
introducing you other characters uh you
know I really enjoyed the fact that you
know they made
just a random bullet train so
entertaining I don't have I have no clue
how they did it no now obviously 16 cars
10 cars is for regular people six six
cars are first class
and in between there
you're trying to figure out how these
dudes getting this stuff done moving
from car to car killing people
uh having conversations when they were
in the quiet car and the girl the lady
from the horror films kept telling them
to shut up
yeah lost you know I thought was funny
is when uh it is it was limited lemon
was the black dude right yeah he's from
the the TV show Atlanta they sit there
and they keep talking he's like he's
like
and he's like he's like we're in the
quiet car and then like after okay let
me just put the spoiler thing up let's
get straight into it man let's get
straighter all right listen guys at this
point in time we're going to talk about
spoilers for the for the Netflix show
bullet train okay
now we're going to give you some stuff
without giving you all of it we're just
going to give you some some of the Big
scenes that we like yeah and they and
this is the last part of the show by the
way I want to keep the spoilers stuff
towards the end that way you can still
you know pick up enjoy the show and you
know we'll go into that uh what I really
liked about this movie is just how
engaging it was with all the characters
everyone came together it was like there
was a reason everyone was there and you
were thinking uh for instance uh the the
maiden attack this his son dies and and
you're thinking oh God like what how how
it happened at the end they're like did
you really kill your own son he's like
he was a jackass like he needed to go
the dude who is white death
I didn't see that coming
I did not see it coming I didn't see
Shannon Tatum popping up didn't see it
coming
I didn't see Sandra Bullock
didn't see that coming
I didn't see
Zaza Beats
that's that character bull ain't really
been on anything in a while though so I
can could see how she was probably cheap
they probably got her on the low but no
she was in the last movie with Channing
Tatum and
was in this movie you know what yeah I I
actually I'm starting to think he might
he he he might be bisexual or something
like every time this dude is in a movie
it's about some suspect stuff did you
have you ever seen um this is the end
have you ever seen this at the end where
are they yeah yeah they're on a truck
guys at the End of This Is the End
they're on a truck and he's like watch
him meet my [ __ ] and he throws them out
there and it's Channing Tatum oh on a
dog collar like yeah he had a whole smm
thing so in this joint you know he
looking at Brad Pitt but he like yo man
he look good we gonna do some is this
the part where we do the sex stuff like
it's crazy
um
how the snake ties into stuff
yeah that's like I knew that snake was
gonna be like someone that whole time
but I didn't know it was gonna bite
ladybug
what's funny is like
the moment he got bit I knew he was fine
because he already got that we gotta
talk about how he's sitting there and
she's like if you get bit if you get
stuck if you get even a little bit of
this it's gonna kill you so she she
drops it and falls on his left on his
foot and he they get there
they have like this awkward stare and
he's like are you going for it are you
going for it and she picks it up he's
out of Mr part all right so it fell in
his hand and so now the poisons in him
he takes the syringe out and stabs in
the neck
knowing his shoulder he's standing her
shoulder and he injected all of them
and
then he's like you got 30 seconds
so he he looking at her to reach for the
antidote so he can know where it's at
yeah yo he is so fast he grabs the
antidote puts in his neck as soon as she
goes to reach for it you know what I
love is she's sitting there like like
she's sitting there like falling on the
ground he's like you don't have a backup
and then she's not saying that obviously
he's like man you gotta come prepared he
said you wouldn't think this out did you
you know she's sitting there she's
sitting there like crawling on the on
the trays so he's like you want some
water you do you need a blanket he said
do you need me to Hold Your Hand
I I yo listen it's so many scenes it's a
it's a very it's a it's a hilarious
action adventure movie it's hilarious
and it's so cohesive
tell me you watched it all the way
through yeah I did
all right so you saw who was driving the
Tangerine truck
was there like an after cut scene yes
you did see it who was it all right
I'm I'm gonna tell you off here oh okay
all right because it's like one of those
Marvel end credit type of things gonna
be another one of these hell yeah they
gotta be because remember they showed
you Deadpool
but he's the one that took the day off
oh yeah I love that when they're sitting
there yeah right Reynolds in this movie
not sure he was only in it for a couple
seconds but yeah what's funny is they
sit there and he's like what was his
name Chase
Chase he's like he's like uh they hire
Chase and he's like I'm not Chase
he said wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait sir wait wait sir
um you got me wrong I'm not checking
he's thinking back to hell yeah he had a
stomach virus and I took his day off
you know what type of luck is this what
type of assassination group has like
like people you can call in to kill
other people because someone's sick
how do you get a sick day as an assassin
and then you got a feeling this is not
Walmart what the hell is this is crazy
all right so we got uh Spartan gold 17
with the two pound Super Chat uh
too
this dude probably not bisexual anything
but he's very comfortable with it he's
very comfortable because they I remember
um
21 Jump Street 22 Jump Street he had no
problem saying like I remember because
Ice Cube was in there did you see that
yeah well Ice Cube in there and a 22
Jump Street they find out that um I uh
that uh the dude uh playing uh uh what's
his name the the heavyset character
uh man I know uh joning something
like well it was it was uh Channing
Tatum's friend someone in the chat his
partner someone put his chat his name in
the chat and they find out that his
partner because they're they're
infrastrating a college and his partner
is sleeping with Ice Cube's daughter he
said that he's like oh you screwing the
boss's wife and he's he's running around
the platform they're on screaming scre I
can't remember his name he's like he's
screwing his wife his daughter he's like
and then he's sitting there and they're
talking he's like Ice Cube's like shut
down don't ever say that again he's like
has it feel that he screwed you yeah
yeah yeah your daughter like you talk
about Jonah Hill yeah Jonah Hill okay
yeah all right
are I vaguely remember that's when it
was in The Briefing room and Ice Cube
was sending them to the college I mean
to the high school
no that's 22 Jump Street Okay 21 Jump
Street was the the high school see they
couldn't do stuff like that because the
Jonah Hill
is full of ground for minor in high
schools yeah yeah yeah out of control
but guys I'ma tell you
it gives you feudal Japan with the
hierarchy of what's going on with
um
what's what's what's the big uh Mob out
there in the Japan
um the Yakuza what's going on with the
Yakuza so you have that aspect going on
there and you have this assassin this
team of Assassins and you're trying to
figure out why they got so many
assassins on this one train and there's
variables there
it is so good the the movie is so well
written and so well directed and the
acting is phenomenal from everybody
everybody that did they part even Bad
Bunny did their part I thought this
movie is a must-see
especially dude bro must see
right yeah yeah you get your wife
together you get your girl together but
if she likes some stuff blowing up
nothing's better than the last scene
when that stuff starts to blow up I
actually I wasn't feeling that part you
talking about where the uh yeah I was
feeling all of that stuff yeah I didn't
like it because I felt like up until
that point there was a lot of
unrealistic stuff especially home boy
jumping on the bullet train and somehow
not getting thrown off so I felt like
there was stuff uh you know but when the
Train derailed and no one got seriously
hurt I was like yeah this is this is
definitely went way into non-realistic
land but you know
I love how how they showed you why
ladybug didn't get hurt
because he hit the uh yeah you know when
you first saw that movie at the start I
knew there was something up about that
there was something up about that
because because like he wasn't she the
person wouldn't let go the briefcase I'm
like why would anyone that's dressing up
like that hold on to it there's no
reason he punched them in the face yeah
he's like they will let it go yo that
thing got hit a couple times in that
movie
he said attic is into chick flicks yeah
I've been to anything that's good I
don't care yeah he definitely into chick
flicks I mean he sent me to watch some
stuff so I say I'm cool this week I'm
you're gonna find out how much of a b
movie fan I am how much cheesy Stuff I
do love I'm uh so all right let's get
down to the brass tacks of this stuff
what did you give it what did you give
it uh
I gotta give it a four like yep I'm
right with you four popcorn four popcorn
baby yeah not a perfect film cause I got
some unbelievable stuff that happened
but it's a full popcorn baby
yeah I think I think we both got to give
that four that it was it was so good
like after about 10 minutes into that it
didn't take long either like I did feel
like it was a little a little slow at
start remember I told you after I LPS
like oh no King like I try to watch it
yeah he hit me up I was like just and
then I was like you know what let me let
me go ahead and start it and that night
it was like three in the morning and my
girl she's like don't stay up all night
AJ and I was like I won't and then I
started watching that I was like I guess
I lied like I went to bed at like five
because I couldn't stop watching it like
I'm sitting there that that movie like
probably shortened my life by a couple
minutes because I was eating watching it
like three or four in the morning it was
good though it was really good I
recommend everyone in here to go
straight to Netflix you know yeah
especially you guys want to go above and
beyond man this is this is viable if you
want to support them like yeah that's
how good this is like most times this is
what you want to have this is the first
movie we've reviewed on here that I
would say is worth buying if you want a
Blu-ray copy or something it's that yeah
it's it's worth having in your
collection it's something that I would
see again I think uh Brad Pitt uh
Resurgence as a leading man
in this uh new iteration of himself
is gold and he and he did absolutely in
the comedy section I can't I got to
bring that up again because it's like
it's like I said he's done comedy in the
past but not fluent like this like I
could see this is his Lane now with his
because I think he's gotten to the point
where he don't want to maintain that
ball like uh like a buff body anymore uh
because you could clearly see he was he
wasn't in shape like he normally is no
but I mean he's he's
he is in Old demand shape great shape I
mean he's he's he's in great shape your
old Elsie did really good job or he did
that like comedy thing or fight club
like I think like oh yeah you talked
yeah when he was uh this guy yeah but I
don't think
she was this funny in Fight Club like
his fight club had more serious tone
this I'm not even joking chat this man
did nothing but say funny stuff from the
time this movie started at the time it
ended and it was just like it was like
that ditzy com uh comedy where he did
not want to be a killer it's like we
want to be he didn't want to be there he
said he's like he didn't it's somebody's
day off I mean it was his day off and
somebody called out sick and he's in for
the other guy and you know it's funny
when so he he he has a briefcase full of
money somewhere on there and then they
get to this part where there's a door
opening because he's trying to get off
the bullet train he's like look it's In
First Class it's in the trash can I'ma
go to go to miniature or something
evaluate my life peace and he's like I'm
not late you leave he's like of course
you're not
you just sit there and he's like and you
could see him looking at the I thought
he was gonna run like
I thought he was going to wait till like
the last 10 or 15 seconds and like run
right to get off the train you know what
I'm saying you know why I knew because
remember the stop before then
the train he was going to get off the
train but it wasn't a full minute every
stop that the bullet train goes to every
every station that it hits it only stays
there for one minute and it goes so one
stop it went to
it wasn't a full minute it was like 50
seconds he was like oh that wasn't a
full minute and he was trying to get off
at the 52nd Mark and just be done with
it but that wasn't to be not at all not
not this movie
I even like the henchmen at the end
questioning the boss's thought process
until to open this briefcase you know
what I like to they had the minorities
opening of the briefcase